bienvenue dans le fait du jour sur
France 24 la stratégie de la Russie en
Ukraine on en parle tout de suite avec
mon invité Christine Dubois Clément
bonsoir à vous vous êtes analyste en
géopolitique du sington Cap Europe pour
la chair risque et cryogyne vous êtes
également auteur d'un livre risque et
manipulation on va voir tout de suite la
couverture influence et manipulation
pardon des conflits armés en Ukraine au
guerres économiques merci d'être avec
nous la Russie qui continue donc c'est
frappes à Kiev mais aussi sur les
infrastructures énergétiques
ukrainiennes quelle est la stratégie de
l'avenir Poutine alors déjà peut-être un
point sur les infrastructures
énergétiques donc le premier ministre
ukrainien avait rappelé que à peu près
28 sites avaient été touchés donc c'est
énorme et on le voit dans votre
reportage couper l'énergie et bien ça va
compliquer énormément la résistance
ukrainienne et rendre l'hiver encore
plus difficile à assumer ne serait-ce
que pour des conditions de vie en termes
militaire au niveau de tout ce qu'on
appelle le commandant de contrôle et
bien là aussi ça va poser des problèmes
puisqu'il va falloir pouvoir alimenter
le système d'intercommunication et on
peut espérer une désorganisation
ukrainienne alors ça c'est l'objectif ça
c'est l'objectif que le que l'on voit et
quelque part viser les structures
énergétiques et quelque chose de
classique dans les conflits quand vous
voulez vraiment essayer de d'asseoir un
pays de le mettre à genoux là il y a
aussi un immeuble donc à Kiev dont on
parle où il y avait des populations
civiles donc ça c'est quoi c'est l'autre
aspect des bombardements c'est la
terreur c'est l'autre aspect alors on a
effectivement cet aspect de terreur
alors rappelons aussi que un des membres
des droits de l'homme un ancien membre
du de la Commission des droits de
l'homme en Russie avait expliqué que de
toute façon même les plombiers pouvaient
participer à l'effort de guerre en
Ukraine et des facto que techniquement
il y avait plus de civils ce qui
permettait ce type de frappe alors
c'était pas un membre du gouvernement
mais tout de même du premier cercle donc
ça pose un petit peu l'idée et ce que
vous arrivez aussi c'est que selon ce
que l'on voit c'est que les
bombardements ont touché la totalité du
territoire ukrainien excepté la région
de soumis au nord ce qui permet aussi
d'essayer de si vous voulez d'étaler
l'effort ukrainien et de soulager les
lignes de front donc du nord-est et du
Sud-Est où les Ukrainiens se battent
contre les forces russes et récupère du
terrain doucement mais sûrement on fait
de grosses percées et voilà donc on est
sur cette approche là si vous voulez
donc casser un petit peu le moral au
niveau des populations sur un temps plus
long rendre l'hiver beaucoup plus
difficile et les manœuvres complexes et
disperser la capacité de des forces
ukrainiennes sur la totalité du
territoire il peut le faire encore
longtemps ça peut durer plusieurs
semaines ce type de stratégie où est-ce
qu'effectivement à un moment donné ça va
s'essouffler est-ce qu'il a suffisamment
de missiles alors ça c'est c'est
effectivement tout l'enjeu donc vous
aviez parlé notamment de ces drones
qu'on appelle les drones kamikazes
certains ont été filmés venant s’écraser
dans la capitale dans le centre de la
capitale à partir du moment où vous
arrivez à maintenir votre
approvisionnement et bien vous pouvez le
faire de manière plus ou moins longue et
puis vous pouvez utiliser différents
matériaux donc effectivement des drones
ce type de son des drones
là ce sont des drones des drones
Iraniens qui ont été qui ont été
récupérés même si il a aussi prod elle
aussi des drones mais il y a eu un
renfort de ces séchettes 136 précisément
et vous pouvez avoir des frappes dites
en artillerie donc relativement en
profondeur plus des frappes de missiles
donc vous avez différents moyens de
venir impacter le territoire ukrainien
et particulièrement si vous utilisez
notamment la Biélorussie comme pas de
tir pour une certaine partie de vos
frappes ok avantage de ces drones ils
sont beaucoup moins déclables ils
arrivent justement à être manœuvrés dans
des endroits où les missiles ne
pourraient pas aller alors c'est
l'avantage du drone si vous voulez c'est
que vous pouvez le piloter et vous
pouvez cibler ou il va aller en limitant
finalement d'avoir un impact humain
c'est pas comme si vous avez un avion ou
voilà ce genre de choses néanmoins c'est
drone là sont relativement lents ne
veulent pas très haut donc arrive quand
même à être interceptable ça veut pas
dire que tous le soin donc ils en ont un
certain nombre qui sont qui sont
interceptés par les Ukrainiens même si
là qui va demander qu'il n'y ait que
très peu d'informations qui soient
filtrés dans les jours à venir aussi
bien pour les avancer que pour ce qui
pourrait être d'éventuels défaite
justement pour ne pas venir obérer les
manœuvres un mot sur la mobilisation
partielle de Vladimir Poutine il parle
eux les Russes du 200 000 personnes
mobilisées on a vu donc des rues sont
fuis le pays que certains donc ont été
envoyés au front d'après ce que j'ai pu
lire après à peine à peine une semaine
de formation enfin on a l'impression en
fait que c'est encore très désorganisé
quelque part très amateurs pourquoi
parce qu'il y a eu un facteur d'urgence
c'est-à-dire que cette conscription
partielle a été demandée de manière très
rapide et d'autant plus rapide que si
vous voulez les commissariats qui gèrent
en fait le recensement est d'envoyer ces
hommes et bien doivent aussi gérer
depuis le 1er octobre la conscription
classique d'automne donc ils sont un
petit peu ils croule sous la tâche ce
qui fait que certaines régions ont
essayé de récupérer les hommes très très
vite quittent en avoir qui finalement ne
soit pas employables pour des raisons de
santé et par ailleurs quand vous faites
appel à des gens qui ont eu déjà une
opération enfin une expérience militaire
et bien vous pouvez jouer un peu sur la
réglementation et ne pas leur faire
passer qui était initialement prévue
puisqu'il y avait cette expérience des
hommes ça marche pas dans tous les coups
mais ça peut être fait néanmoins à la
marge et ça a été fait mais ça a été
fait et puis ce qu'il y a eu c'est que
des hommes y compris de Crimée ont été
envoyés sur sur le terrain et sur la
ligne de front avec une urgence comme
vous le disiez qui était finalement de
ramener des hommes pour faire ce qu'on
appelle du stop loss donc limiter les
pertes et ralentir l'avancée ukrainienne
coûte que coûte même si c'était sur de
la chair à canon même si c'était sur un
coup humain est-ce que ces messages des
mers russes parce qu'on a pu lire ça
aussi pas mal dans la presse qui ont
donc des fils mobilisés on a
l'impression est-ce qu'elles sont plutôt
résignées ou plutôt révoltées alors en
fait le mouvement des maires de soldats
russes date des années 90 elles avaient
été particulièrement actives après la
Tchétchénie qui avait été
particulièrement sanglante et elles
avaient réussi à obtenir des
modifications notamment sur le service
militaire néanmoins elles avaient été
particulièrement muselée depuis le
lancement de cette opération spéciale et
là on voit qu'il commence à y avoir
effectivement des remontées et notamment
parce que cette mobilisation partielle
contrairement à ce que l'on a vu depuis
le début ne touche pas les mêmes strates
de la population c'est à dire que là
n'importe qui peut être peut être appelé
et de voir aller se battre en Ukraine
dans les conditions que nous savons
alors que la Russie a bien du mal à
endiguer les avancées ukrainiennes et
que des facto il y a évidemment
énormément de pertes on pense aux morts
mais on peut penser aux blessés graves
aussi on peut revenir handicapé à vie
donc il y a une espèce de remontée à ce
niveau là parce que vous avez des
populations notamment des grandes villes
éduquées qui ont un niveau de vie que
l'on qualifierait de CSP plus si vous
voulez moyen qui n'envisageait pas
forcément d'y aller et qui se trouve
impactée et en même temps c'est chat on
sent une forme de résignation oui alors
il y a quelque chose qui est très
ambivalent dans la relation que que les
Russes en règle générale nourrissent
avec leur armée c'est à dire que on a
quelque chose de très fier on va tous
aller au défiler et on va pimper les
poussettes des petits on va les décorer
en char mais en même temps au moment de
la conscription dont je parlais
précédemment et bien beaucoup de ceux
qui peuvent essaient de trouver des
moyens d'échapper à conscription alors
qui en en étant blessé qui en reprenant
des études qui par Podevin ou par
corruption et moyennes contournées en
fait exactement pour ne pas rentrer dans
dans le service militaire l'Union
européenne va former on l'a appris
aujourd'hui les soldats Ukrainiens
parlent de 15000 soldats Ukrainiens ils
seront formés sur le territoire européen
est-ce que c'est nouveau ça alors il y a
déjà eu des formations qui ont été
faites dans différents pays de l'Union
européenne notamment l'Espagne de de
combattants Ukrainiens qui ont fait un
turnover notamment pour les former sur
des matériels qui étaient qui étaient
livrés donc des systèmes d'armes
occidentaux avant leur livraison donc il
y a déjà eu en fin de compte tout donc
ce n'est pas nouveau mais c'est un peu
non plus généralisé peut-être il y en a
plus 15000 c'est beaucoup 15000 soldats
15000 c'est assez important et c'est
surtout que là on le ferait avec une
espèce de de coordination alors qu'avant
on était beaucoup plus sur du travail en
bilatérale d'état à état donc c'est plus
fort
un mot sur tout de même et sanctions
contre l'Iran que demande les Ukrainiens
aujourd'hui parce que justement ils
disent que c'est drone sont exportés par
l'Iran en Russie elle pourrait renforcer
ses sanctions Union européenne sur cet
aspect là en particulier contre l'Iran
en tout cas il réfléchit en tout cas il
est réfléchit puisque faut pas perdre de
vue que le but des sanctions qui ont été
prises par l'Union européenne était
d'empêcher la Russie d'être en capacité
de pouvoir maintenir son effort de
guerre donc effectivement là il y a une
si vous voulez un voie de contournement
qui permet de réapprovisionner sur du
matériel qui est utilisé et qui est
utilisé de manière létale contre des
populations civiles donc là par rapport
au droit international et bien on vise
ces populations sans intérêt ni
militaire ni stratégiques et sans faire
ce que l'on appelle de la ségrégation
donc oui il y aura à mon avis un enjeu
maintenant ce sera sous quelle forme de
quelle manière pour les rendre pour les
rendre efficaces tout en sachant que
l'Iran avait expliqué ne pas avoir fait
de livraison de ces matériaux un dernier
mot puisque vous êtes aussi spécialiste
militaire sur la justement
contre-offensive ukrainienne continue
quelles sont les conditions pour qu'ils
continuent à avancer est-ce que l'idée
c'est vraiment une course contre la
montre avant que les rêves l'univers
n'arrive alors en fait il y a plusieurs
choses déjà ils sont et je pense qu'il
faut le garder à l'esprit même si je
vais un peu enfoncer une porte ouverte
ils ont besoin d'avoir un maintien du
soutien notamment en armement puisqu'ils
en sont complètement dépendants même si
ils sont extrêmement efficaces ils ont
fait preuve d'une approche stratégique
et de commander le contrôle qui était
tout à fait pertinente mais si vous
n'avez pas d'armement et bien tout cela
tombe à l'eau donc ils ont vraiment
besoin d'un soutien très fort au niveau
des alliés et ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'ils essayent de regagner le maximum
de territoire ne perdons pas d'esprit
qu'à chaque fois ils doivent aussi le
stabiliser c'est-à-dire le déminer
c'est-à-dire le maintenir c'est-à-dire
récupérer voir s'il n'y aurait pas de
saboteur donc tout cela doit être fait
de manière concomitante avec des
systèmes de roulement jusque là ça a été
fait avec beaucoup débiles et c'est un
travail qui est assez long et ils vont
avoir aussi besoin et bien on en revient
à des problématiques d'énergie parce que
l'hiver en lui-même est un tueur
et que quand bien le froid arrive les
blessures et l'évacuation des blessés
sont plus compliqués vous avez toutes
les maladies saisonnières qui peuvent
arriver et qui elles aussi peuvent
franchement opérer la capacité d'actions
énergétique merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous à Christine Dubois à Clément
analyste en géopolitique du sington Cap
Europe pour la chaire risques et le
créogin j'espère que je me suis pas
trompé merci d'avoir été avec nous